E SENATE TONIGHTSSING THE RESPER
DEMOATVOTING YES,.THE BILL PROTE
ALONG WITH 12 REPUBLICANS.
E HOUSNEXT
WEEK.
AND ONCE IIT IS
EXPECTED TO DO, IT GOES TO
ES
NOW, PEOPLE E
ANATE OF ALL OF
TH YES WE SHOU AY
CHTHAT BECAUSE BTICT, THEY
ETE THESE DAYS.
BUT WHEN YOU UNPACK THE RESPECT
R MAIAS
OTE TO IT.
LET ME BACK IN
JUNE, ROE V. WADE WASED BY THE E
N THE SUPREMCOILWOUDSER
ABOUT IT.LD IMTUNGRESS TO TRY TG
IL TO CODIFY TTIONS THAT SUCH RS
WOULD Y OF A
EME COURT OR A COURT FTHAT REAS.
TO ENSURE THS
SUE COURT'S LANDMARK 2015DENWILL
LL DECISION?
WHAT DOES IT CODIFY WHAT
?
T EXACTLY.
SO, THE NEW LAW D ASSURE
LL BEFR MARRIAGE,
GA OF A COUPLEEXR ETHNITY OR NAE
REQUIRED TO RECOGNIZE MARRIAGES
LID IN A STATE WHEN
THE NUANCE AND WH SAID.
T VE ST
RE THEEDS ARE IR
IT.
THE STATE, THEREFORE, STILL
HOLD A PRETTY POUL CARD IN
ITS ABILITY TOIND WHAT
Y IS A SO-CALLEDID.
NOW, THIS NEW LAW WILL NREQUIREU
ICENSET'
SOWHTH RETAINOW?WELL, THWOCALLEO
ST IN ITS LANE.
AND THE REST OF THRO
TO THE STATES.
IF THE EM
TO OVERTUROBGE, WHICH
LEGALIZEAME SEX RR, A
ATSSAW
SAMEEXAGE.
BUT THTAOULD BEED TCOA
E FED VEO  A BIG EXCTI
UNCLE SAM WILL NOT BE REQUIRE
TO PCTYGAMIST
GES.
BECAUSE THE FEDERAVEMEEFER TA M,
PROTECTION THAT OVERFILLED
CIASRIGHT NO
BU TT ALLOW
MARRIAUNE E OCUAL PROTECTI OE 1O
NOT MEAU
STETHAT IS WHAT YOU CALLGNITTHS
DOES NOTALL OF THEDS
THOUGH, THEYLYTHEIR HAND I MATT.
OF POLITICAL GAMES HADO
TSSFULLY,
QUESTION IS,EN THAT
HAND, LET'S SEE IF THE VOTERS
AT STATE THE
N DEAL IT
COMES TO CIFYI TTS.
I ING IN JIM
PLAINTIVHE5
OBERGEFELL VERSUS DG
LAD TO SEE YOU.
WEOMGRAM.
HOYOU?
BECAUSE SOMEONE LOOK AT THIS,
COUNTERINTUI.BE CELEBRATE THE
CO
D ATIRST GLANCE, IRESS ARE
MARRIAGE ON
UT THAEXACTLT'S DONE.
ANSE
AND YOATING THIS
NATE VICTORY FOR NOW?
>>O, I AM NOT CEI SPY THAT AT
FALLK ULD THSUPREMEN
COURT OVERTUBUT , I FIRIOUS
THCALLED THEPECT FOR
IAGECA ACT
PECT LMMITS, OUR MARRIAG, OUR
RELASH OR OUD HAT THD ALLOW STAO
PLES, WHERIS THE
Y RRIAGE IN THIS COURYOES NOT.
YES,HAPPY THS AT LEASTHIT
EDULD
OBERGEFELL BOVTUM HAPPY TOTHIS,S
OPPOSETO HAVING EVERYTHINGN AWA.
ENS WHO AREPECT FO TE E E ONCE N
MARRIAGEIS NOTTH
THAT'SSU T THIS COUNTR
R MARRIAGE ACT
, RIFYNE
UL TO TAKE AWAY FROM
TO BAN SAME RRIAGER OWN , THE
RESPECMARRIAGE THA IS VALID IN A
DIFFERENT STTO T
SORT OF NOTION.
BUT YOURNTS WELL TAKEN
T SAT E DTOFCT
ND THERE'S AISFRATOR
, WHO IS OUT O
TDAY XPLAINREMEMBER, IT WAS UNR
>> FNRATS IN THEREPUBL EXP
TODAY AND IT, WE DO
WELL BY TAKING THIS STEPIN
OTHEREVVIEW B BY THTOLERATIHEM.
MY VOTE YOU HAVE TO CRINGE
WELL>> ABSOLUTELY.CAT
R POINT EARLIE
POINT ABOUTT EY CALL HOMEES
.HAVE TO LAUGH AT THAT.
BECAUS THIS ACT
AD RELIGUSSO-CALLERES FREEM
A IT,S ATOLERATING ANYONE ELSES
PPLTHEIFFTH
R RELIT THAN ANY OTHER,
TH SPHERE.
M MEANS THAT
E THE
HEE LIGION OF CHOICE, THEIR FAIH
HR
HOUSE OF WORSHIP.
THEIR
O PERSECUTE OTHERSOT SHA THAT S.
SO, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
OUT KOWTOWINEOPLET PREFERENCEORR
INTERPRETAONPARTICULAR RELIG